do you know who's hosting this year
snoop dogg
okay okay so it's not
oh i think my like hosting like the
person i'm like i feel like snoop dogg
is hosting everything so i'm like um um
where do you think it is i know it's in
beijing so i was making sure that you
knew it was in beijing
so game begins now
hey what's up y'all it is a big time of
year for us in the sporting community i
i say us because
obviously i'm a 2021 sports emmy winner
not once but twice over i won two
we're sports emmy winners
whether it was a mistake or not i earned
it and i'm keeping them and i'm not
changing the plates even when you send
me the correct ones emmy people the 2022
winter olympics are about to begin on
february 4th everybody ps you can watch
on nbc you like that
there are so many different winter
olympic sports but there are also
apparently so many sports that used to
be but are no longer in the winter
olympics i don't know why they got
kicked out we will uh these are
questions so i'm being challenged to a
game of is this a winter olympic sport
let's see if i can guess them
skeleton
is skeleton a winter sport
skeleton
i'm gonna say no that's not a how is
skeleton a winter sport i don't
understand
it skeleton is a you felt good about
your air
you're wrong
it's not the script i just enjoy
skeleton is a winter olympic sport oh i
remember that i didn't know that's what
that was called
skeleton is a current winter olympic
sport where a competitor rides face
first down a frozen track on a small
sled known as a skeleton bobsled did not
actually know the name of it but yes i
do
i do know this this always scares me
this comes back there's like nightmares
of like even in like elementary school
and people were like i'm gonna go to the
slide head first i'm like why would you
do that
like it just i feel like you're gonna
break your neck why even why risk it for
a playground fun time like i don't get
it but people do what they do
skeleton is a sport
current one
icicle javelin
i don't think icicle javelins is for it
but i really want it to be like a big
giant job that's my icicle
i feel like this is a sport in um
frozen in the movie frozen this is not a
real sport yeah icicle javelin is not a
winter olympic sport but wouldn't it be
fun
[Music]
oh
ski drawing
ski drawing is ski during a winter
olympic sport
i don't know what the hell it is ski
joint
skiing
during i don't
know i'm going to say yes i'm going to
think maybe you're skiing
and you're trying to
go through rings or you're trying to aim
for rings i don't know i don't know what
it is i feel like i won the game of bs
it is a former winter olympic sport
let's find out more
oh
ski drawing is where a human on skis is
pulled behind a galloping horse
skijoring was held solely at the saint
moritz 1928 winter olympic games
that just seems
like a lot of work
i feel like that's why they got rid of
it i'm really glad that's not one
anymore it seems weird but also kind of
miss it because that would be really fun
and look at that cowboy he's like
come on
i feel like i feel like this is what
people in ranchos do when they when it's
when they get just hammered and they're
like i have this really great idea i'm
gonna pull you behind those
ski ballet is ski ballet a winter
olympic sport i feel like you're going
to break your ankle that's like a dumb
thing i feel like you slip and fall and
and snow and ice like why would ski
ballet be a sport
i'm going to say no
oh
ski ballet is a former winter column why
olympic um
ski ballet is a mixture of figure
skating and skiing
performing a two-minute ballet-like
routine outdoors on skis
on skis demonstrated at the 88 and 92
winter olympic games
it well it's probably not a thing
anymore because people are so confused
i'm still confused by it
oh my god
oh my god look how joyful that is
oh my god that guy he is like fame i'm
gonna live
that's amazing
oh my god that guy i'm gonna picture him
all day today
ice sculpting
it is competitive ice sculpting a winter
olympic sport
if it's not it should be i love
sculptures i think it's the most amazing
thing to be able to do that i think that
ice sculpting
should be if it's not i'm going to say
yes
it isn't
it's an art form i mean you got to be
strong
what would i sculpt you
i would just sculpt her eye sculpting is
not a winter olympic sport although
people do compete in it okay so it's not
but it should be
whoa
biathlon triathlon is biathlon a winter
olympic sport
what the hell is biathlon
biathlon hmm
i'm gonna say
okay that's one so it's like a bunch of
things maybe if it is something because
it's like a travel like you know like
athlon like i feel like it's like maybe
um
i'm going to say no
i'm going to say 51 is not a winter
olympic sport
that you're like
triathlon like you know i i would be two
i know but like what
i know that's what i was saying wait
well that's what i was saying because
like a traveling so i thought maybe like
but then i was like what is the biathlon
what would they be doing the biathlon is
a race that combines cross-country
skiing and rifle shooting once again
these are is this a real thing still
yeah
i'm gonna watch this
you know what would be cooler because if
they it wasn't rifle shooting it was bow
and arrow
oh
caser essen
quezoresin
that was my german um yoderman um
is kisser essen a winter olympic sport i
mean
first of all what the hell does keras
mean so i don't know
um i'm gonna say sure yeah
oh nope it is not it is not a winter
olympic sport what is it
okay there isn't is just
german for eating cheese
oh
it's good i like cheese that's the end
of the game
i wasn't very good at it but anyway good
luck to everybody in the winter olympics
it's such a cool thing for the family to
sit around and watch together um
thank you for working so hard i know
it's probably weird circumstances that
y'all are under because everybody is
because of you know the pandemic so um
thank you for all your hard work thank
you for entertaining us and
congratulations on being
an olympic athlete if you were to ever
compete in the winter olympics what
sport would you be good at
oh
eating cheese kaiser essence
i will be eating some cheese and
enjoying a charcuterie board
with some pinot noir while watching you
be athletic
[Music]
you